what is a computer do you know what it
used to be before I actually civil it is
now it used to be someone's job so in
1930s on ones you actually see lots of
people whose D job was to add up numbers
and compute so that principally is they
go fashion electromechanical devices
have rank through into things so they've
got a little bit of mechanism manner but
so often it just be the bridge computers
currently I've generally systems which
will run an algorithm and take some
inputs process things and generate an
output so they have some sense of
manipulating what we call state
information they will change values of
things
sporting a computer used to be kind of
easy right so if you think of the makeup
in film then Owen dollar brain right so
you know the spot in the computer was
easy fell during lots of flashing lights
nowadays though that scan much harder to
see what a computer is so so the same
process of computation happens of taking
things run an algorithm generating an
opah but they're much more embedded in
the world that surrounds us saw so I
often ask people how many computers do
you think you see in a day all right
so fast your that question without
thinking about it I'm saying ten twenty
if depending on what I'm doing that day
I'm something down soft other questions
you probably don't know all right so so
how many CCTV cameras did you drive by
okay how many saints or doors that you
open and it's these things are so
invisible we're not noticing them so
what becomes a computer and we think of
a computer is really crowded so I can
open my wallet and give you picture of
my children which has a computer built
into it so credit cards are great the
Penan Chet is exactly computation so
there's an algorithm that runs stored in
the chip on the computer that's embedded
in this create account and so when this
is pushed into machine you type in some
numbers it runs on an algorithm through
those numbers and verifies that this is
indeed the personal identification and
whether it's on this chip their
computing is happening on on this device
so that's a one example of a kind of
compute computer most keys from most
cars no have wrecked systems which
recognize and run the seminar sort of
code to check that their key is indeed
the key associate of a first car either
car itself well yeah we'll have you know
I think you think your betaine your pain
computers you could all probably count
for most of those in your car okay so
your brakes for example your ABS system
will have a little computer that'll be
running and measuring whether your
Britain you've got the brakes on and
whether the appropriately applied and
then continually running it to do that
and they'll be talking to a whole host
of other computers your engine
management system will be making
decisions as to when to fire things and
you know all that know all of this kind
of seamlessly kind of happens around you
and and so that all of that can I
invaded computation is a big part of the
world that surrounds us is this what
people like you think of as computers
when you say the word computer to your
colleagues you're thinking about all
that stuff so so the kind of computing I
do put as definitely that's what I mean
by computers I mean lots of modern
computing is just about that and so you
will hear for example many of my
colleagues talk about future smart
cities where the sessions are made and
about how the city runs them by
computers that monitor and respond to
things and look at these things you
colleagues that have put large computer
systems and to run complex organizations
like Heathrow or Heathrow Terminal 5 and
or the Channel Tunnel and thinking about
the signal saves those to us or
computers right there are as much
computers as the ones that you directly
interact and that n direct interaction
is increasingly becoming a part of how
we think of the world so you will hear a
lot of people talk about big data and
how big data will change the world
one of the many powerful ways in which
they've done often law what what they do
is they take the information from lots
of these little computers and then put
it all together and then use that to
make judgments a system that is run in
Boston and runs on smart phones and it
uses the accelerometer on your
smartphone it can identify when you're
driving and when you're walking but
better than that by measuring
everybody's accelerometers that are
there it's been able to draw maps of the
potholes in the Boston area and schedule
the repairs for those potholes so every
time someone drives over when it gets
that jump they know where happened and
at 15 people do that jump they can tell
where it is and depending on how big the
jumpers from the state of the pole and
they can spot its degradation all right
so that kind of mass of information from
all these computers that we live with
becomes really important one minute you
told me a story about yeah this scares
the life out of me so that and it makes
me think that's brilliant so that well
so the challenge over stay here is how
to reap the benefits and avoid the
pitfalls so how to how to do that and
then not make it something that
threatens civil liberty okay or
something that is scary
so that's the challenge for us as
researchers as hope to as how to do
those things obviously the definition of
the computer is something that does
computation yes what is computation like
you talk about algorithms data States I
want to know where the line in the sand
is between something that is computing
and something that is not it's just a
piece of perhaps the best way to kind of
describe the differences to give you two
cards okay so this is one kind one card
which is a credit card and this is my
university account okay both of these of
electronics and them okay so this is
what's called a RFID radio frequency ID
what this has in here is a little chip
and a big aerial so whenever this gets
put up against or saying
ador reader the coil is energized and it
sends the number so the door knows that
number and then the door can decide to
open no decisions have been made Bella's
champ and it's not taking any input so
that doesn't feel like it's doing any
computing for me this takes inputs and
that then makes the decision and does
something and the doing of something
here is looking at those numbers and
checking that those are the correct
numbers through a process of encryption
okay
so generally speaking when we talk about
computers the general model that we have
in our head is empat process and open
and that processing can do can be very
trivial it can be two plus two equals
four that's compute or it can be these
are the signals for tunning the break on
the speed the waiver conditions decide
how much brake power to put on so the
computing is that processbook wire by
you take those inputs and make
intercession the rules by which you do
that we often talk about those
algorithms
you
so we hardly ever talk about computers
right so because what we talk about is
the things computers do 18 megabytes and
let me say again 18 megabytes not 8 2
gigabytes